so far I've been telling you about the
theory of quantum mechanics and how it
tries to answer questions about reality
today we're going to do something a
little different and actually question
quantum mechanics itself I've been
looking forward to this in this video
we're going to look at a paradox
Einstein helped create to disprove
quantum mechanics to understand it we
need to know about an essential
ingredient in quantum theory
entanglement entanglement isn't actually
something limited to quantum consider
this example you have two objects one
red and one white you put them into
boxes and shuffle them around now if you
open one of the boxes and see the object
is red then you know without having to
check that the other box has the white
object in it so we say that these two
objects are entangled which means that
knowing something about one causes you
to know something about the other
without ever having to look however
quantum entanglement is much more
interesting than this garden-variety of
course the culprit as it always is in
quantum mechanics is superposition let's
go back to our example while the boxes
are closed we don't know which state the
object in each box is in red or white if
it were truly impossible to know which
isn't actually the case in everyday life
but let's say it is this time then
quantum mechanics tells us that each
object must be both red and white at the
same time but it's even weirder than
that there are two possibilities either
a is red and B is white or the other way
around but superposition tells us that
all possible things happen at once so
the state of the two objects is both a
is red B is white and a is white B is
red now this is a bizarre superposition
what happens if Alice checks object a
she collapses the state of object a
which is weird but as usual but she also
collapses the state of B which she
didn't even touch I'm sure at this point
that a lot of you are skeptical why
should we accept the quantum picture
when it's obvious that the classical
version has the same results by a far
less convoluted method couldn't it be
the case that objects aren't
Ashlin superpositions at all this is a
very good concern and one will be taking
seriously we're going to try and build a
test first let's notice something in
quantum mechanics these particles are
not independent of each other in a deep
sense you could argue that the classical
particles aren't either but here's the
difference in the classical class
measuring one of the particles say
finding out that it's red doesn't
actually turn the other one white in
fact it does nothing to the other one
the objects already had a color all
along on the other hand according to
quantum mechanics the objects have to
affect each other otherwise each object
is in a superposition of red and white
and Alice could measure hers and find
its white but this doesn't do anything
to be superposition so Bob could measure
B and find its white as well but this
can never happen the EPR paradox is a
brilliant and simple argument that
exploits this difference between the
classical case and the quantum one the
authors wanted to show that even though
it seems like both the classical and
quantum explanation can explain this
experiment the quantum one actually
can't it's a proof by contradiction
which means that you assume something in
this case that quantum mechanics is true
and then show that that would lead to
something impossible happening therefore
the assumption must have been false all
along actually we don't need to assume
all of quantum mechanics is true just
one little fact we need to assume that
if we have an entangled pair a and B
then measuring a really does affect B we
saw that quantum has this quality while
classical mechanics does not but we
don't need to worry about superposition
etc for this argument just this one
little fact alone ok so now say that our
boxers get shipped to the other sides of
the universe to Alice and Bob Alice
opens hers a split second before Bob
opens his Alice finds her object is red
so Bob must find that his is white but
let's think about what must happen in
that split second between when Alice
unboxes her object and Bob does the same
a must tell B that it's been measured
and what resulted decided to be or else
be won't know what to do but that
message has to go an awful long way in a
very short time in fact even light
couldn't go that fast this is a big
problem if you've heard of Einstein's
theory of relativity you might know that
the fact that nothing can go faster than
the speed of light is the foundation of
that whole theory therefore accepting
our assumption that a and B can really
influence each other is equivalent to
pulling the rug from underneath
relativity to Einstein this was
impossible so he concluded that the
assumption must be wrong let's not be so
certain what are the possibilities the
first possibility is that the assumption
really is wrong well that definitely
rules our quantum mechanics but it's
actually even stronger than that it says
that no theory we're measuring one
object changes the other object can ever
be true but then how can we explain that
a and B always have opposite colors we
must do it the way classical mechanics
did ie none of the quantum weirdness no
superposition no randomness no
uncertainty principle so these are the
two possibilities either we must believe
that nothing can go faster than the
speed of light and except that quantum
mechanics is completely false or we
accept quantum mechanics but we discard
the theory of relativity we can't have
both